and on the brand side really bringing
that in also from the very beginning
from really acknowledging the limits of
what a corporate social media account
can do what corporate content marketing
can do you need these Bridges to your
target market whether it's in attending
events and festivals and conferences or
empowering influencers to tell the story
of your product has to be there from the
very beginning can't be an afterthought
because those will be ways to
infiltrate to make the sale to grow to
be a part of culture otherwise if all
you're doing is running ads there's only
so far that can get you and that can get
you far you can sell a lot through ads
but you're not going to be a company
that's part of Pop Culture that's on the
tip of people's tongues that has
ambassadors and evangelists out there if
all you're doing is running ads welcome
to 20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking about Partnerships
and not just any Partnerships but
Creator economy Partnerships and at
scale and at light tricks with Jacob
Schwartz well we're going to be diving
into the whole world of the Creator
economy with Jacob and we're going to be
understanding a little bit about the
incentive systems the different
challenges that are arising with the
Creator economy but mainly the new
opportunities that are coming about it
welcome Jacob
Jacob thank you so much for joining me
I'm 20 minute leaders today how are you
great thanks so much for having me
thank you very very much for being here
we're going to be talking about a space
that I'm so dumbfounded on and I think
it's something that uh generally where
we're not giving it enough credit yet in
this incredible incredible emergence of
the Creator economy as such a
foundational movement in terms of how
everything is about to change obviously
from travel to Fashion to entertainment
and decision making and I obviously it's
going to go into all the different
sectors eventually and but I'm really
excited to have you here and to to hear
about your perspective on this economy
and where your journey has taken you so
again thank you for being here of course
thanks so much for having me it's
definitely a whole world and would take
hours and hours to get into 100 so
briefly connect the dots from you
looking back you know about your journey
we were claytritz just so that I can get
it as foundational understanding of how
you've entered this Creator economy
space yeah sure so as far as I see it
I've been in it from the beginning
before the buzzwords and titles for it
existed I got online really early AOL
1.0 back in the day at College I studied
Film Production I always loved
storytelling digital culture the impact
of the digital Revolution on our society
and culture and always interested in how
companies how people share their stories
and connect with people online so
there's the whole emergence of social
media and people creating content on
those sorts of platforms and now sort of
the evolution or maybe a shift from
Brand voices to individual voices seems
like a Natural Evolution and you know
it's not necessarily rocket science
creators are just people telling stories
and now technology allows them to
connect with bigger and bigger audiences
and brands are seeing the impact of that
while at the same time people don't
necessarily trust companies and don't
want to just get marketing messages and
ads from companies so it's not
necessarily rocket science you as a
person are much more likely to be
influenced by another human that
entertains you that educates you as
opposed to a brand and so for me I found
a way to make a career of all the above
through places like MTV and VH1 and
other TV and media companies like
Discovery to companies that were trying
to be a big part of culture also like we
were and now with lightrix which is
making tools used by millions of
creators
incredible so the equator economy at
large can you give me you know your own
perspective on the emergence of it how
you know what was sort of the trigger
and what are we seeing unfold here
before our eyes in 2022. yeah I think
kind of like I mentioned we're seeing
the rise of the voice of the individual
and the tools available to help them and
Empower them to tell their stories to
connect with the audience whether it's
niche audiences who just want to see a
great you know on Tick Tock I follow
this great Creator is just a lock
picking expert and people send him locks
in the mail and he buys locks and shows
how he picks those lots that's
entertaining maybe it's a niche audience
it's just a fun thing to see two of the
biggest most mainstream celebrities
musicians and others and you see what
for example people like the demilio
family are doing that I'm lucky enough
to work with now that have sort of
passed the evolution of just being
digital creators and now into more
mainstream celebrities with TV shows and
movie and music and all of that it's
really amazing and it's a challenge for
companies to go beyond what they're used
to doing which is marketing strategy
buying ads writing copy for ads and
figure out how to tap into this space
how to partner with and Bridge their
story with the story of individual
creators or human beings who have flaws
who have their own stories to tell and
how to work with them to drive business
impact is a whole Revolution where you
can control everything the more you try
to dictate to an influencer the less
they'll be able to influence Their
audience because they know what works
with their audience not necessarily A VP
of marketing in a corporate headquarter
somewhere
yeah I mean I'd say I'm sorry I I love
to tackle these questions these there's
Nike questions from every two ankles one
is from the angle of the Equator and the
other from the angle of the business and
and so let's start from the Creator side
can you share with me what are you know
the real the pain points or the journeys
that that currently a Creator goes
through and and what are the tectonic
shifts that are happening on the side of
the Creator today yeah sure great
question obviously very complicated and
in-depth question I think if you break
up the Creator economy on the Creator's
Side by smaller creators people who
maybe have an ambition to you know not
have a different job but it's the number
one job kids want to be when they grow
up is to be an influencer now so what
does that mean when you're at that stage
where maybe you only have a hundred
followers and you want to get to 10 000
followers and build an audience around
that it's a very different pain points
than when you have 5 million followers
and maybe a staff of three or four
people and are negotiating brand deals
for hundreds of thousands of dollars and
suddenly you find yourself having to pay
employment benefits to people and figure
out tax returns and retirement plans
it's all really different pain points
just like any other industry there's
that Evolution people go through from
being small to bigger and bigger and
each creator has their own way of sort
of evolving and some might want to move
more behind the camera and build
businesses around it and some want to be
this far and in front of the camera and
maybe use their Fame to springboard into
other more traditional things like being
a movie star or a TV presenter or
something like that
it's all really really different totally
different ball games
and so in terms of the the way that
they're that they're building it the way
the The Leverage that they have the ways
that they're creating their content are
there major trips that are happening or
is it sort of state of the art as it is
now yeah no definitely not shifting
every single day we see now all the
changes happening at Twitter which is
insane we see bigger platforms like
Snapchat and Tick Tock competing with
each other copying features trying to
woo creators in different ways with
different methods of monetization
they're sort of the big brother in the
House YouTube which has been paying the
most money to creators for the longest
time and is maybe the most stable and
long-term place for creators to monetize
themselves so constant changes and as
your growing Creator when you start
growing maybe after a few brand deals
maybe you hire an assistant or a social
media manager to help you that first
time you have to give someone a p your
password and hope that they're not gonna
do something wrong with it you know
there are pain points at every step of
the game then as you get into having
managers agents legal teams financial
advisors it's all so different while at
the same time the marketplace is
changing so much creators are working
very hard to find other ways to monetize
Beyond just brand deals because maybe
that's where they make the most money
but it's the hardest they don't want to
be seen as selling out to their audience
they don't want just have ads in their
posts so more and more ways whether it's
merchandise or subscriptions or micro
payments and different platforms like
patreon and others allow for different
models like that it's fascinating that's
why we could be talking about this for
hours
and so if we're looking now from the
business side from the from the company
then goes what what shifts are you
saying in terms of the way the companies
are thinking yo you briefly mentioned
you know the fact that companies
understand now that the traditional
averages of marketing are slowly
becoming less relevant and it is through
the voice of the people and it is the
authenticity of me you met Humane nature
of that of the creators how do companies
adapt now to these shifts in the Creator
economy yeah I think it's challenging
and I understand their pain and
frustration you can't see working with
influencers in a very scalable way it's
not just need numbers in a spreadsheet
as you might have with your Performance
Marketing with the ads you run each of
these people are individuals you know
there can be creators with a small
amount of followers who maybe have a big
ego or maybe just went viral and are
struggling to figure out how to
translate that into a business and then
you have bigger creators who maybe have
larger audiences but that are less
engaged and what you can expect out of
each of those kinds of creators is very
different not necessarily the same sort
of metrics as you see with Performance
Marketing so it's a very different
change in mindset
how it impacts brand awareness how it
impacts things like your Performance
Marketing is all really really different
and brand marketers are learning to let
go more trust to the creators there's
only so much you can dictate if you
actually want them to influence Their
audience you have to trust their
instincts which
people aren't used to doing when you're
an executive at a brand you think you
know best what the call to action should
be and maybe what the hashtag should be
and things like that and it's not very
scalable it takes a lot of Manpower a
lot of human touch building
relationships you know you might send a
Christmas present to an influencer you
worked with that they really appreciated
and go above and beyond when they're
working with you there's so much
psychology these are individual people
they're humans with a soul they might
have a bad day they might get burned out
the Facebook ad manager never gets
burned out that's always there for you
to work with just your numbers and
settings and so very different mindset
and so how is this how how are these
relationships forming today is it very
much and then sort of in an individual
basis you have somebody from a company
reaching out to an influencer and trying
to start making a relationship or their
platforms starting to rise in this third
guard how are you seeing this landscape
yeah it's really all the above there are
a lot of middlemen online platforms for
example light tricks acquired one called
Popular pays which connects brands with
influencers who have registered and
there's some sort of vetting process
there and a little more creative thought
about making those connections then
there are fully automated platforms and
obviously lots of Brands sending direct
messages to lots of creators and vice
versa smarter creators pitching
themselves to Brands they think are
relevant for them and then so much more
working with Brands is just one way of
monetizing as a Creator it's a whole
career path it's a whole business from
the side of the Creator so they're also
thinking about subscriptions and
micropayments from fans and other
experiences and Merchandising and
offering swag Live Events all that kind
of stuff so it's a whole new world and
that's why we call it the Creator
economy it's an entire economy it's not
just a brand pays X to an influencer for
three Instagram posts and that's it
that's a really short-sighted maybe
old-fashioned way of thinking about it
and so you you are saying it as um as a
career path so you think that this is a
you know the a lot of the people that
are engaging with this Creator economy
they're looking at it as a career path
and not as a side hobby to something
else that they're doing absolutely and
there's so much more than just what I
would call the on-air Talent the
on-camera talent you see now more and
more job postings for people in that
world they're job posting for things
like YouTube thumbnail Creator because
if you're great at creating thumbnails
for YouTube videos the Creator you work
for will literally make more money and
that's worth it for them to pay you to
do that so there's going to be more and
more job titles we see in this economy
who's on camera is just the tip of the
iceberg and of course there are plenty
of very popular accounts whether it's
meme accounts or infographic accounts or
other things that aren't based on
personalities on a single human being on
camera and it's all still the Creator
ecosystem the Creator economy me it's
really exciting
incredible and looking at your own
journey within the Creator economy how
how have you grown in your own mindset
and understanding what were some of the
major I guess tips that you've gone
through as new group to understand with
this industry what's happening I mean
you you mentioned you started from day
one so you lived through these different
changes and accepted those changes which
I guess maybe
10 15 years ago most people wouldn't
necessarily understand that this is
what's going to happen
yeah sure it's
really interesting yeah I you know
growing up in New York watching MTV
that's like at that time that was the
center of Pop Culture then getting a
chance to work there was really awesome
so I got to work at the time with Tila
Tequila the number one person on my
space because MTV gave her a show and so
to see what it's like taking someone
like that with their digital influence
at the time to promote a show to try to
drive tune in to a cable channel from a
social media presence was real a really
New Concept and over the years seeing
how there started being more and more
digital marketing commitments in
contracts with talent for TV so that
you're not just casting an actor to be
in a show but you're also analyzing
their social media and that's part of
the casting process and how their
accounts are doing and will they also be
able to have an impact on marketing that
was all new ideas where the marketing
folks would be in the room with the
casting people on reality TV shows let's
say and then as that became more and
more natural now you're at a point where
it's from day one what is the social
media presence to what extent is their
digital influence around this bringing
in influencers let's say to have a part
in a movie because then they'll help to
be a part of marketing the movie even if
they're not the star and on the brand
side really bringing that in also from
the very beginning from really
acknowledging the limits of what a
corporate social media account can do
what corporate content marketing can do
you need these Bridges to your target
market whether it's in attending events
and festivals and conferences or
empowering influencers to tell the story
of your product has to be there from the
very beginning can't be an afterthought
because those will be ways to
infiltrate to make the sale to grow to
be a part of culture otherwise if all
you're doing is running ads there's only
so far that can get you and that can get
you far you can sell a lot through ads
but you're not going to be a company
that's part of Pop Culture that's on the
tip of people's tongues that has
ambassadors and evangelists out there if
all you're doing is running ads and
connecting with people who have
influence on the ground in culture is
what companies need to do to be able to
go to that next level of sophistication
as a company
in karma so what do you think today
within like Jason I know you love your
job that is already from our few
conversations I I understand it that
much tell me a little bit about why what
is that video and why you love it so
much yeah sure so these days and I won't
bore you with the history but these days
we focus a lot on our relationships with
Talent of all kinds from small creators
that we work with to bring in content
for our inside our app experiences as
well as on our social media so those are
consider more creators we're not
necessarily working with them because of
their influence over an audience but
they're using our apps in great ways
that we want to feature build tutorials
out of for example all the way up to
bigger influencers and celebrities so
like this deal that we have with the
demilio family who took an equity stake
in the company and have really become
broad-based ambassadors so at any given
time you can see across Charlie and
Dixie and Mark and Heidi their accounts
posting content edited in our apps are
engaging with our social media in a much
broader way than just here's a bunch of
money you owe us five posts over this
time and that's it so I love going
deeper with these relationships and
building more broad-based long-term
Ambassador relationships that's much
less transactional and short term
what is she grow to understand about the
motivations of the creators you
mentioned before that they're trying to
tell their own story they're here to to
be offending and to influence through
their own personality what have you
understood about sort of the way they
work and how you can best partner with
them and support them on their Journey
yes I really you know a lot of this is
not rocket science it is about these
buzzwords that people throw around now
about authenticity and integrating into
the influencer it's not just here's the
script for the ant please read it and we
hope your fans will purchase immediately
in the short term but by developing much
broader long-term relationships then the
partner can start to really integrate
the brand into their content and then
their fans actually see oh they actually
use it they actually like it it's not
just that they got paid for two posts
and then I never hear about it again but
is it in the background is it
mentioned in other ways are they
engaging with the accounts on social
media in ways that obviously you just do
more as a normal human and not just a
paid Advertiser for someone so that's
really what we strive to do and what I
like to do so if I'm working with an
influencer trying to craft that longer
term strategy and for example at light
tricks these are at editing apps so I
don't care if they use our apps on their
other brand deals and people know it's
edited in video leap for example our
video editing product that's totally
fine it's not exclusive it's not
competition they're actually using these
tools and you can see it even on things
that don't look overly promotional
because a big pain point with the
influencer is always to Pine that
connection point that bridge between the
brand messaging the brand goals and
Their audience and it only works when
it's win-win-win poor everyone a brand
can't dictate too much a can a brand
doesn't want influencer to sell out
their audience the influencer doesn't
want to do that and the audience doesn't
want to feel like they're just being
sold and monetized so if there's a way
for the brand to provide value to that
following even if it's entertaining and
something fun and random and again not
just a Cheesy ad so when I'm working
with someone it's not necessarily about
oh they have to be in perfect hair
perfect makeup with the perfect lighting
from their ring light to deliver a
speech that I gave them about the brand
that's the last thing I want I just want
them using the product integrating maybe
wearing the logo every now and then or
something in the background or you see a
cup on their desk that's a lot more
natural and again building that
long-term relationship and awareness and
maybe through that just maybe Their
audience will actually be influenced in
a way where just doing one or two cheesy
poses they won't actually be influenced
if you're a follower you know oh I guess
good for you you made some money from
this brand but that doesn't mean that
I'm gonna go out and buy that brand
product now
this term I think I love that
distinction at the end it's how do you I
actually influence and how do you create
that trust and and it sounds like okay
well it's much more helpful
way of doing a partnership but it takes
time yeah it takes time and money it
kind of makes the right stomach and
patience to really build that
relationship over time in a way that I
understand can be really nerve-wracking
for Brands who want to see oh how many
sales did it bring us yesterday
it might take time to build the
relationship and then next Christmas
suddenly there's a big blist in sales
because people have your brand in mind
but the only time people hear about your
brand can't just be in ads and can't
just be wrapped in messaging that says
click here buy now download now that's
the only time they're hearing about the
brand there's only so far that can take
you
thank you so much for coming in for our
Channel if we are in yours your
understanding and passion for the queen
upon you really appreciate it my
pleasure insurance on the side and thank
you for sending this time thank you so
much Michael
foreign